a question that comes up a lot amongst
creative people do you have to live in
LA to launch a career yeah especially in
writing yeah you don't have to live in
LA to launch a career but it's gonna be
harder if you don't in certain way so
what I would say is first of all think
about their stages so the first stage is
writer development you know most people
start out they don't quite realize how
hard it is and they have a little bit of
a exuberant confidence which i think is
great because it gets you writing you
know I know for myself if I knew how
hard it was gonna be I don't think I
would have even started and when I first
I'm like oh I'm good this isn't that
hard I've seen this is as good as that
movie and and then at some point comes
the point where someone tells you and
shows you you're not close to where you
need to be and then the question is what
are you gonna do about that and so
there's the phase of writer development
and I've talked about this and I won't
go into too much detail because it's in
a lot of the videos that I've done for
you guys at film courage but it just
briefly is everyone has inherent
strengths weaknesses in blind spots and
your job is to figure out have someone
help you figure out where the blind
spots so they become known weaknesses
and then how do you attack weaknesses
and turn them into strengths how do you
do structured exercises that are a
little bit beyond what you're capable of
so you're going to fail but you're gonna
learn from those failures and eventually
be able to do it so then you're going to
become better if you just keep doing
that so Dziedzic Li you can become
enormous ly better so the first phase is
writer development you do not have to be
in LA there are advantages and
disadvantages to being in LA there are a
lot of classes and workshops and so much
educational opportunities in LA but the
great thing with the internet my
workshops are online video conference
you have people all over the role take
them I'm not the only one
there's certainly if you want to take
classes or workshops there are a
multitude of options that you can do
while you don't live in LA also you know
in LA you can go to the writers guild
you can go to there's these events where
writers talk well if you don't live in
LA you can watch the film
videos and online you have so much
access so in terms of education now you
can do that anywhere an advantage of LA
is you're going to be around like-minded
people forming communities you know when
I went to film school I didn't grow up
in LA when I came down here you know was
a bunch of us we all have the same crazy
dream we supported each other we watched
movies together we discussed movies we
we read each other scripts who really
helped each other and when one of us was
feeling down the other people would
encourage them you can do that anywhere
in the world now with social media like
you you have to put more effort into it
but you can create communities I don't
think it's the same as face-to-face but
I think if you live somewhere in the
world outside of LA you can educate
yourself you can grow your talent you
can form communities now have to work
harder at it it might not be quite as
enriching as if you were in LA but you
can certainly do all that and let's not
forget LA is a high cost of living place
to live you know for people sometimes I
live in LA they have families they have
careers they have businesses there's a
lot of costs involved to move to LA so
you when you're developing your
abilities getting to the point where you
can write the kind of script that can
launch your career you don't have to be
in LA and there's an advantage of not
being in LA because the biggest mistake
writers make when they're in LA is to
keep meeting people in the industry and
networking and they show scripts to
people before they're ready before the
scripts are good enough and they blow
their first impressions and they can get
blacklisted so there's an advantage to
being outside of LA while you develop
your abilities now let's say a writer
has gone through the developmental stage
and they have scripts at least two that
are good enough to get representation
and to be shown and start to take
meetings so then let's call this the
launching of the career phase this is
where it's very advantageous to be in LA
it's not a requirement
absolutely have to but it's very
advantageous so if you're not in LA
what's gonna at a minimum you're gonna
have to go to come to LA
for two or three weeks a two or
three-week block multiple times a year
because what's gonna happen is your
representation is going to take your
script out to various you know producers
networks cable companies streaming
companies also they might be showing to
show runners and there's going to be a
round of meetings 20 meetings 25
meetings some of these meetings are
generals where they're like loved your
scrap we can't buy it
but we want to meet you they want to see
who you are I want to make sure that
you're someone they want to work with
they want to have a relationship with
you they want to read your next script
some of these meetings are you're going
to be pitching a project we loved your
script we wish we could buy it can't we
want to be in business with you what
ideas do you have it's easier to sell a
pitch than a spec in the TV industry
most projects are sold via pitch so
you're going on pitch meetings and you
know you pitch at a company and then
they'll bring you back to meet someone
else then someone shows up there's a
series of I met three people that Scott
free before I met with Ridley and pitch
to Ridley or you might be meeting with
show runners who might be interested in
possibly staff in you on a show so
there's a round of meetings and at the
end of that round maybe someone's bought
the script or your pitch or staffed you
and maybe not and if not you write your
next script and you go on another round
of meetings and as my agent said if you
go through three or four rounds of these
meetings and no one is hire you then
you're the biggest a hole in the room
like there's something just wrong with
you that nobody wants to be working with
you but assuming you're not that person
three or four rounds of meetings you're
going to get your shot so at a minimum
you'd have to let your representation
know I can be in LA like for this two or
three week window and then they're gonna
try to schedule all those meetings in
those two or three weeks here's a
challenge there might be some great
meetings are gonna miss because they
can't fit it into those two or three
weeks the other thing is very common the
night before a meeting or the day of the
meeting they reschedule and that's
actually often a good thing because as
you work your way up you're starting
meet with more senior people at the
company you could actually have the
authority to hire you or by a pitch or
the script but they are overseeing
productions they have a very chaotic
life and they don't have complete
control over the schedule so they're not
being rude but a lot of meetings get
bumped and rescheduled so if you're only
here for two or three weeks that meaning
may never get rescheduled or it'll get
rescheduled but you may not be able to
do it or what happened to me as I
pitched to some people at scott-free and
they said really is out of the country
for a month well schedule when he comes
back because he has to hear the pitch
and then I got a call like three days
later from my agent saying Ridley's in
town today he has a window can you be
there in an hour
because he wants to hear the pitch now
if I was back in New York or Toronto or
Topeka Kansas that meeting doesn't
happen does that mean I never would have
sold metropolis the pitch to really I
don't know maybe maybe not but the
advantage of being in LA is you can do a
last-minute meeting and when meetings
get reshuffled you can always attend so
it's not ideal to come out so what I
would say is in the writer development
phase it doesn't really matter where you
live in the launching if you can come
here for six months or a year it's going
to be helpful it's going to increase
your chances
I know agents and managers that won't
sign someone who doesn't live in LA
because it's going to be harder I know
more agents and managers who would sign
someone who doesn't live in LA but if
they're trying to sigh between two
people to sign and they they feel pretty
equal about both of them and this person
lives in LA and this person doesn't
they're gonna go with this person and
not this person but if this person is so
exceptional they'll sign them all so you
know you can always do meetings over
Skype but it's not the same you want to
be in the room if you can I have worked
with writers in South Africa in
Australia in Alaska who have launched
careers that did not live in LA they
were able to come to LA you know for
three weeks or four weeks twice a year
they knew there were some meetings that
they would probably miss out on but it
was
really important for them to stay where
they were at until they had a career so
it can be done it is it is I would say
it's gonna be it's going to miss your
chance of somewhat I'm sorry
significantly but it's good to miss your
chance of somewhat it's gonna make
things a little more harder maybe take
longer but then again the trade-off for
a lot of people is I have a life here
and my kids go to school I own a home I
have a business and I don't want to
uproot everything so it's it's a
trade-off that people have to make I
would say if you can come to LA I would
I'd come here for the development phase
but I'd definitely come here for the
career launch phase now once you've
launched your career if it's feature
film writing you live anywhere you know
I did that for ten years I could live
anywhere in the world I see a lot of
writers who don't want to be staffed on
shows they just want to sell original
material and they'll sell two or three
scripts or pitches a year and that's a
very nice income and then down the road
if you do that enough times one of those
might get made and that could be a very
nice income so if that's the case you
have to come here for pitching season
maybe two months out of the year I know
people that are here for two months out
of the year you know they rent an
apartment for two months and then they
go back to New York where they go back
to Toronto they go back to South Africa
obviously if you want to be staffed on
the show you're gonna if you get staffed
on a show you need to live where the
room is you know and that's usually in
LA or sometimes New York but usually LA
so I would just say you don't have to
live in LA it is helpful it might
expedite the process it might make it a
little more likely might make it easier
so if you can if you're on the fence I
would absolutely come to LA but if you
have very strong reasons why you want to
stay put as long as you can be here
twice a year for three to four weeks
then you can do that and if someone's
here taking meetings and then they have
additional time yeah what are some
things they should be doing not just I'm
not not sightseeing wise but like in
terms of getting to know the industry
feeling the temperament yeah whatever
so it's a great question
and and the answer might might surprise
some people or not let me let me share a
big mistake that rioters make I know I
would have made this I was just lucky so
I didn't have the opportunity to make it
so you write a script and let's say
you've really written an amazing
exceptional script and you'll you'll
know because people will want to meet
with you there's a big difference
between an agent or manager trying to
get someone to meet with you as opposed
to people calling the agent manager and
saying everyone's buzzing about the
script I finally looked at it I want to
meet them and the managers I quill
they're they're booked for the next
three weeks they're like I will I will
cancel a dinner I will cancel lunch like
they are moving their schedule to meet
you you'll feel it when you go in a room
it's really exciting and what's gonna
happen is like someone's gonna buy that
script and and but then there's a
there's a whole process for all the
deals to come through or someone's
buying the pitch and it's like it's it's
a done deal and then three months later
it isn't it'll this happens all the time
and I guess you know it'll go all the
way the finish line is a very last
second for something you can never
before see your anticipate done happen
and it's now been three to four months
since that buzz from the script and you
were sure this was landing a career and
it suddenly doesn't which is very common
and that's when your agent or manager
says well where's your next script and
the problem is a lot of writers they are
not writing another script because they
are taking all these meetings which is
it's a full-time thing because you know
pitches have take a lot of preparation
and get notes on the pitches people are
reading your script they're asking about
the first year they have some issue
you're doing a lot of creative work in
preparation for these meetings it's
really time consuming and especially
let's say you live in LA you know you're
working your day job trying to support
yourself like it's exhausting and no one
really has time to do this and be
writing another script and they know
they're gonna launch a career but then
it doesn't happen and then the agent
manages where's your next grab
don't have one and this was really
problematic for a lot of reasons for
most people when you know you're gonna
get a deal and it falls through
emotionally that's not always the best
time to be starting a new project you
know not always our most confident place
secondly you kind of get a script really
quick or the industry's gonna say you
wrote this one script it was amazing but
you're slow I mean and they're gonna
forget about you like that like that
buzzes you got has a shelf life and it's
less than you thought so ideally if
everything falls apart you have another
script like in three weeks and I don't
mean to say three weeks is the magic nut
but you want another amazing script soon
and keep this in mind most people don't
get hired on their first round of
meetings they get hired on their second
or third round of meetings because now
they've proven they're consistent
they're not a one-trick pony and they
can do this repeatedly because there are
some people who can write one great
script but they can't write multiple
great scripts and I have seen writers
who go through this round of meetings
their project is getting made if there's
just not this person attached and this
attached and it's a done deal and then
it's not and this four months later and
they're demoralized and it can't bring
themselves to write because they feel
like that was the best script I could
write and it wasn't good enough and then
their agent her managers like where's
your next script and like I don't have
one and they're like when can you get
anyone and it's like I don't know and
then you don't have an agent or manager
so when you're going out on those
meetings especially when it looks great
especially when like this is leading to
a career and nothing can derail it I
don't think you should be doing the site
scene I don't think you should be trying
to take the temperature of the industry
I think you should be taking meetings
and writing hope for the best prepare
for the worst and so if it doesn't
happen in this round of meetings you
have another great script soon
thereafter and if you repeat this
process you're going to get a career and
if you don't repeat this process then
you better be really lucky on that first
round of meetings the very first place I
went
with scot-free and they bought my pitch
so that can happen the very first place
you walk in the second place the third
place gets a deal it can happen it
happened for me if it didn't happen for
me and I went through that round of
meetings I didn't have another script
now would have been demoralized and it
would've been really hard to write
another script and I don't know what
would have happened and I might have
lost my agent and I might have lost all
that momentum that doesn't mean you
can't start over again but you actually
start over with a strike against you cuz
they're like oh yeah you're a slow
writer oh yeah you had an agent but you
lost an agent these don't look good
these are not good things on your you
know your industry resume so when you're
taking these round of meetings it's so
important that you write and I would say
for people for people who live in LA if
possible and I know this isn't possible
for everyone if possible when you're
going on that round of meetings and you
have a partner and say you're married or
in a serious relationship see if you
can't pre negotiate that during that
time you don't have to work and they
work and support you and them or you've
save enough money because if possible
and I know for some people this is
impossible but if possible when you're
going on those round of meetings and be
really great if you didn't have to work
and make a living that you have two jobs
those meetings and your next script
you